yeah welcome to this video playing alive
again yeah let's see what who's some the
expert in Sicilian I have I have very
little knowledge but sometimes people
really play Knight f3 c5 and their
gamble that no one's going to play you
for now spending a bit of time at least
Quincy 7sm a rare move yeah just should
I do that probably see 3d form looks
like good idea getting up from center
and hoping to somehow make use of a
screen position be four deforms the idea
and right here I'm winning change the
tempo or deform if he takes now then
I've got Knight c3 coming textext 93
coming with attack on b5
yeah I thought 93 would be good anyway
but John maybe I'm I'm wrong he can take
see true and take you form hmm yeah this
wasn't exactly the plan hmm wow what a
shame
ah don't I have Wow don't even have a
vaguely playable move amazing yeah I
really relied on 93 but this is not
working can even takes it to play before
Queen a for Bishop c6 some didn't really
a calculator this okay I really I don't
have a move maybe this isn't too bad
actually with Knight c3 coming of course
it's it's not a real plan sacrifice or
anything but maybe I can at least try to
make a fight out of this not sure how it
should take now maybe with this okay at
least I'm winning a tempo on the bishop
yeah maybe a man maybe I'm able to play
Knight e5 or D 5 D 5 maybe I am maybe
there are some slight slight chance at
least
I take it and play nine to be five or d5
I could d 5 is not working i take c form
might be five queen bee summer there is
no real continuation
yeah the snot this isn't greatest all
you
I hope you get some counter play oops
this is probably more slip take back
requested yeah this was such an obvious
mostly by except that usually okay how
to continue now take a 6am i'm just a
pawn down basically yeah oopsie 8
amongst others but Brooks the ages
probably good enough try to hang on wait
could have taken on f7 well not really
but this is the kind of stuff I need to
I need to watch out for some some silly
sacrifice based on my active night-
pieces objectively I'm really just a
pawn down sure what you should play the
o 95 maybe at f.2d five hmm can I take
now actually
I think I can I can I can take now yeah
yeah this was lucky King takes this
Queenie 6 check at night XD five I get
my piece back and Knight c3 bc 3 it's
okay King takes Queen e6 i geti seven so
I'm reading also Queenie six now it's
really a big threat threatening this
discovery so if you place a move like
and I'd say queen term night d three or
so i can take you six probably yeah
quite lucky to get in either seven
don't really seems maybe queen 37 or
something yeah but this is very silly 95
yeah yeah take this and then 95 was my
idea should be good just him its own
it's a bone at the end and this weekend
weekend king yeah obviously have an
excellent result considering i was born
down for nothing okay i cannot really
take anyway only two and then need need
some space
check
I'm sorry okie eight
the i8 salam it's just a pawn but not
not so easy covering h4 and they cannot
you can never take because I'm of goopy
aid yeah should I go yeah the rook
endgame is so probably have an idea
though and so with rook to see tuned and
then approaching the king as a rope to
e2 and now using the king I can play
broke a three indices this is the
epicardium no okay I didn't didn't
appreciate this idea
time learning yeah it's not easy because
I'm so passive check
black forfeits on time yeah he's some
Sun losing on time yeah I shouldn't I
shouldn't have gone for this route game
game I didn't I didn't see this idea I
thought I just approach I mean while i
was when i was playing this one as i
thought okay i cover on the second and
then I approach the sea pawn with the
kingwood he's got this this is strong
the rukon f3 quite good yeah thanks for
watching this game